hello Evan hello today today is our
anniversary true 11th year that we met
today no not that we met we started
dating H I wonder what it was from when
we met oh that's something to think
about actually we didn't really talk to
each other when we met what just no why
not cuz I remember when I first met you
uh you were you were in a marriage and I
just know of you and I never talked to
you were you scared
uh cuz you were kind of my instructor so
I was a little nervous nervous yeah
you're like I'm going to marry that man
oh well while are you're in a marriage
wow okay so what's your plan for today
what's my plan for today yeah we're
driving to Blue Mountain and we're
spending the weekend and we're going to
get away from the city and relax and
enjoy each other's company and do a few
surprises
is what's your plan for today follow
your lead all right let's
[Music]
go what's the first stop
Evan uh I don't know what's the first
stop first stop is
is we're going to figure it
out we can't get into our place until
4:00 and it's noon so we're going to
we're going to first stop is figuring
out where we can park that's a good
first stop and then head out to the next
first stop which is a
surprise so here we
go so you figure out what we doing first
we're getting our
tickets date pass to what that Blue
Mountain to be in nature with my
[Music]
animal so it looks like you changed
something of the tickets EV
what did you change we don't get into
our place until 4:00 and there's some
things that we can't do with the dogs so
we're going to do some pretty intense
hiking until 4: and then we're going to
drop off the dogs and we're going to do
a Mountain roller coaster uh
ziplining and then take the open air
Gondola to see some night hiking
Extravaganza let's
go this is this is where we're going to
go later on
tonight you are here okay we walk from
here around here to
here and now we got to go up to here and
over or maybe we even go here whatever
that is Lookout Point and crossing
over and down for that teo's tired
though
[Music]
go
how are you doing Evan pretty good
pretty messy yeah the hike is very messy
look at Timo and
Tristana yep
muddy yeah we're we're over halfway
up
okay we have to climb up this hill this
is a very Steep Hill it's not that bad
we'll see we'll see
how me and the dogs can
do as soon as we get up to the hill we
find our path and go
down let's go Timo let's go
Teo see this is the muddy part that's
where we came from we walk we climb all
the way up I'm
exhausted how you doing great ready go
good for you look at Timo he's he's a
little dirty just a little bit yeah
timo's having fun yeah you tired
Timo what's a g Evan uh it's a Night
Trail that's all lit up okay so so we
better we better wear like a boo
uh I think you're on like this I think
but we can okay that's what we're going
to do tonight everything going to be lit
up in the hike
Agora what did you find Evan our Trail
down Trail down how good is the looks
great you ready to go for a hike this is
where we're going down guys let's go
down here this is
[Music]
it
we made it down are you filming me yeah
you should film you why cuz you uh took
a little bit of a spill yeah well I
hesitated here you Nina I hesitated Nina
took his tumble and then I slipped I I
was I was running down the hill at the
last part and then uh at the end I was
like oh okay I need to slow down I need
to slow down and then I fell right at
the bottom yeah if if I just keep going
then I'll be fine she was in she's in
good spirits though okay let's go it's a
mess yeah and this street here I don't
know if you guys can see it car Michel
[Music]
Crescent we got a message from the
Airbnb so that we could go to the the
place oh great we're going to clean up Y
and head out again in an
hour okay this is our place for for the
night well the two days night two nights
yeah Evan found this good job yeah you
found yeah that's a big uh Big Comfy
area here yeah I like this very bright
you got a barbecue outside lot the
windows and
then where's a little kitchen okay right
there's an upstairs too how many rooms
are here I think there's like three
rooms there's a room here a nice
bathroom here a double room
here and then I guess our room is the
Master's
upstairs anybody watching want to stay
with us we got two extra rooms
yeah oh nice pink size bed nice view of
the pond mhm
bathroom all right good job
Nina I wash you Teemo you're now all
clean clean yeah and you you had supper
so you're not hungry you're begging me
for food and Evan had a nap yeah you had
a nap cuz it was a tough hike it was a
tough hike we were sleeping I
fell yeah I'm excited time to go back
out now yeah we're going to go head out
we can't bring the dogs because we have
to do something that they cannot go
on
okay first one we're going to the roller
coaster no no zipline oh zipline I
thought we're doing that first that's
what you said no the zipline closes soon
oh okay so zipline and then the roller
coaster okay then dinner then the
gondola and then the night the nighttime
spectacular okay are you afraid of uh
zipline no no this is a baby zip line oh
okay last time we went to a zip line in
Quebec I went to a zipline with quit
back and quit back with the kids yeah
yeah I had some good relaxed
time
okay good EV you ready let's go you
excited I'm ready is your first time did
I ask that no it's not my first time
okay but I'm it's my first time on my
11th anniversary so okay that's
good well it's not like we've done a lot
of exercise you know extra step with the
harness and the hat oh yeah to go up to
did this how about you
tired do you have fun yeah uh what it
was a little tight okay certain areas
that when you're sitting down and then
when it hits at the end like okay might
talk like this from now on Happy
Anniversary that's funny Walk It
Off sh
[Music]
off okay where do next here roller
coaster uh roller
coaster you have fun kid I almost see a
bug on the way out I have a couple thing
hit on my face yeah I have my mouth WI
like and then a bug hits me in the nose
like w I should close my mouth that was
great that was so much more fun than the
zipline I had it full speed the whole
way did you slow down too I I slow down
when I turn a little bit but otherwise
yeah full that was great yeah that was I
guess you didn't film anything but I was
smiling the whole
time next up we're going to have some
dinner right Evan yep Italian place
Italian place best review in this
Village it had the highest ratings so so
we're going to go eat some Italian
[Music]
onoi I haven't had cheese like a
mozzarella cheese in a long
time you love your pasta with white
sauce
I I'm always looking for a good C most
people don't do it
well you like it it's okay it's
okay A B minus for alfredo I'm a alfredo
sauce now go Nina also got a pasta she
got the the meat
sauce she goes oh it's hot you see the
smoke coming out she said she wanted hot
food there you go
and it's our
verdict very hot very hot but is it good
I like it it's good
perfect good
dinner go back need to take some our
pill Evan just dancing dancing
away when you're up Blue Mountain you
have to get a beaver tow that's one of
the famous one it's very hot dessert in
here woo hot Evan got a square bit
Beaver towel and know show them what's a
beaver towel it looks like a beaver
towel but with a different flavor past
uh what what is this this like bread
flat bread with with dressing on it
score and something I when was the last
time I had a beaver tail I don't know
but that was many years ago years ago
yeah yeah yeah it's very hot yeah got to
I got to let it chill let it chill let
me try it then okay you try it you's
going to give it a bite
delicious
yummy not that
hot
good we went back to the Airbnb to take
our supplements and then now we're going
to go out again to the gondola because
that's part of the we could also hike to
the top instead of the Gonda oh my God I
don't want to hike to the top again cuz
once we get to the top it's another two
or three hour hike right my God n's
getting her steps in today yeah probably
hit almost like 20K today
[Music]
ready sad news sad news yeah Gonda is
Clos it's okay it's not sad but how come
they closer I forgot uh he didn't tell
us he said there's some un unspecified
reason there I think it's Alien Invasion
Al Invasion alien alien attack that's
why they're being so secretive yeah it's
alien are coming okay but it's okay more
more oneon-one time with Nina
okay okay we went to we went to talk to
the the front desk to let them know
about the Gora that is not open and then
she gave us a pass for tomorrow night so
that we can get up it's going to be
colder tomorrow night yeah but that's
fine yeah we have each other to warm her
up oh wow that's good and Nina did some
expert negotiation you don't want to be
on the other side of a negotiation
with n cuz you're going to
lose that's not true that's not true
it's the next day and if you want to see
what we do today click the video right
there next to I think you love it
continue to believe we'll see you there